my name is captain keith colburn I'm a
crab fisherman mr. Naville I own a boat
called the wizard
and you might see me on a show called
Deadliest Catch
yourself about being on the water
working with and against mother nature
and depend on the teamwork that goes
into being on a boat
your heart pumping
I was going to make a list of the
qualities I'm looking for a greenhorn
first of all you've got to have common
sense someone that's going to take the
time to actually think something through
as opposed to just react because it may
be the difference between having five
fingers and having three fingers you
need to get it's willing to not blow his
top not lose his cool in the Bering Sea
where you use about nine words total
five of them get beeped out shut up do
your job so let that roll off your back
is a real good character trait
they have to be both mentally and
physically tough I've seen the biggest
burliest guys basically fold up and fall
apart
instantly Axl's ticket I've seen the
wiry little scrawny guy that can work
his way through the pain and discomfort
everybody will talk a good story on the
dock but once it gets down to game time
all of the things that go into the job
will break a guy really quickly
you